[Music]
welcome everybody to the tonight's class
viewers choice and that means to submit
your games and to first we'll go over
the games are submitted by the player
you know the players who are here and
well-secured will do basically we'll do
a game analysis we will go over your
games and I will point out your mistakes
and by the way this is the most
important thing to get better interests
so you want to make sure you you want to
make sure you know your mistake because
if same mistake happens you don't want
that you don't want the same mistake
happen again you want to make sure you
find a mistake and fix it okay so that's
the idea to remember okay so let's let's
make sure we start this first game was
submitted by a student the present then
then then here he will members at the
club so then your tell us a bit about
this game where are you playing such as
chess come game time this is a time
control that I recommend to my students
to play game 10 or game 15 at least
because that way you have enough time to
think and find out good ideas okay
so game 10 or game 15 got it so II for
French so then plays the French defense
and his opponent plays d5
can you please name this this line what
is this line called
yes advance variation of the French
difference perfect yeah c5
see three because black has a white has
to play the movie three to protect the
center otherwise you will just take it
and then destroy the center and he may
as well lose the e5 pawn Knight c6
Bishop e5 immediately your opponent
didn't play the best move the best move
here is considered Knight f3 Queen b6
and now you have few options here okay
now you have few ups White has few
options a3 is one of the top moves you
can play Bishop e2 and also you can play
Bishop b3 these are all the main lines
here all the decent lines okay Bishop d3
is a gambit yes this is called Milner
Barre gambit so you take you take he
take Bishop d7 and then you want to take
the pawn on d4 so it doesn't have a good
way to protect this if it goes here then
you can jump in with Knight here to put
pressure okay
so take take
but your opponent played Bishop b5
Bishop d7
and now then I have a question for you
or just why not play a little bit more
aggressively in fact here's a question
question for everyone here what is the
best move in this position you think
what is the move that you could try to
do here
absolutely you go clean v6 absolutely
you play Queen b6 okay now are you
attacking the bishop and there is a
pressure on d4 okay and if he takes you
take back with this and Bishop on a6 got
it
but if they we should be seven and now
now Bishop d7 is played and now question
what is then threatening to do everybody
see the threat then do you know your
threat okay let's give a chance to the
other station Jason Knight takes e5 so
let's say if Y plays at the normal
developing move here you have a typical
tactic here because this bishop is loose
piece so you go Knight takes e5 tactic
if he takes back you go back ninety
seven and you're up upon if he goes back
here with this now you just take back
the Bishop b5 and you win a pawn here so
you probably had this in mind when you
play this more yeah very tricky for
excellent yeah the second best move you
played you should go Queen b6 you know
that you should play Queen b6 because
after Queen b6 capture capture let's say
he tries to finish his development now
like that move you say no you're not
cancelling now you stop him from
consoling okay and now you get an
excellent position like this okay next
time to this play the best move in the
position okay don't go for a tricks go
for the best move that you have
available perfect now
Bishop d7 was played Bishop takes his
sexy took and now you made the
interesting additional taking back with
a pawn explain to us why you play this
move which is d4 yeah and take once so
okay excellent exponents to take on the
for once and then play c5 again to
basically break the center but your
opponent late night f3 which didn't
prevent that I think this move is very
interesting we should be three to try to
at least a pose that a little bit you
know to make it a little bit harder for
you to do that
okay you played here Group B eight then
why don't you stay with the plan stay
with the plan uh that all those double
pawns and attack that Center no this is
the right way to play block is slightly
better already
if you try French is a good opening I
recommend this to people who don't know
what to do against e4 to learn it
because you get a very solid position
and a lot of times your opponents are
not very familiar with it because it's
not like first openings they study see
forty-five caecilians a lot of times
people don't pay too much attention then
they don't regard French as anything you
know particularly that awesome maybe you
know but it's you know it's played
played at a very high level played at a
very high level with the good results so
that's a good opening to study if you
don't have anything against efore you
know okay then this is natural okay you
should do this you should do this
because you play the move Ruby it I
don't know I'm not quite sure about this
because it's like a move we don't know
you're making a move maybe it will be
good maybe it's not so I don't know
yeah castle
take
so now you should take back with the
pawn of course right I mean just taking
up where the knife was a pretty poor
choice because he basically allows you
to place if I with the temple so taking
back with the pawn was correct
97 B 396 g3 another poor decision right
you have a light square bishop and
opponent is weakened in the light
squares so this is looking good for your
Bishop c6 okay
c4 I don't know about this month why you
want him to play c4 so you can play so
what's wrong with just developing
develop castle Queen here I mean this is
nice okay yeah you're very very
comfortable
you should just just just put the bishop
only seven that's it yeah or h5 you
should be seven h5 sure very nice you
know that's a good idea - I like this
idea h5 because it will very aggressive
try to attack okay you have a very nice
position so see for this I don't like it
because you weaken your d4 square and
you're giving his knight an outpost and
he kept posting it there okay so you
don't want to do that he did
now if then takes the pawn right what's
the problem here
for now for actually 93 so maybe there's
something a little bit better than that
check yeah then it takes but there is
something a little bit better I think so
let me show you what so here you just
play a simple move rook e1 and now no
matter what you just take the knight
whatever piece protects it Bishop pawn
queen you take and you take back on c6
yeah 93 but it's not check yeah so maybe
take Queen b6 wow this is getting sharp
here f2 is hanging maybe your position
is too good at the opposition is good
enough that tactically you hold up you
know you may okay - Queen c6 by a black
is just doing great - maybe it works
maybe you could have taken the pawn
actually strangely enough yeah strangely
enough it seems like it shouldn't but
because if you take on B here I think
this is just great check mate mate
everywhere okay
so there should be seven did you
consider night if I were you did briefly
it's a it's a 10-minute game it's a
10-minute game also so you cannot
calculate you cannot spend all your time
calculating this we should be here at
for Bishop c5 before there should be six
okay castle f6 Bravo 10 Bravo that is an
excellent move breaking the center
opening up the position to try to attack
that vulnerable King very nice move how
did this idea occur to you or you were
planning this for a while yeah so you
want to break it up and weaken it and
break it open takes Queen takes Knight
f3 another wonderful idea Bishop c6
getting the bishop up there now he goes
back you take now you have a protected
past pawn on c4 his life squares are
terribly weak and now you have this idea
that you can do at some point okay I
don't know if you did that night a5
queen h6 setting up a letter Nigeria
tactic
night h4 yeah position is I had a
question for you then they drew when you
took this did you look at this wolf
what are you gonna do are you gonna save
your look it's strange tactic yeah
it's looks strange but I think it I
think it works unbelievable I think he
just pushes this and wins material
Wow sir that tells us you had to be a
little bit more cautious you know and
take with the Quinn
and if it takes you just take on d2 and
you take the bishop so it's just nothing
yeah you got to be careful because this
could have been a very costly no II five
opening it up ticks
Najee six
Knight f3
look at that look at that
very nice well you you you you want you
wanted you wanted to push this pawn and
then he somehow just well position is
lost anyway so he doesn't matter here
the result of this game is clear now you
would have won but this this is just you
know made the process a little bit
quicker you know just just a little
quicker check take Wow excellent well
what can we say about the game overall
was a great game you played well the few
moments you could have been a little bit
sharper so let me point out so let's let
me point out for your observation so
first thing was they should be seven
second best move okay you went for the
trap it worked for you did you play with
the intention of a trap or you thought
that was just really do your best moon
position my you knew couldn't be six
it's likely it's likely hero fall for it
huh yeah he would likely he would likely
to fall for it yeah yeah absolutely yeah
okay the second observation was here
Ruby eight it's such it's a move that
it's it may work out well for you but
it's it's unclear the usefulness of this
move at the moment instead what you had
to do then capture and c5 and break the
center okay that capture capture c5
alright perfect
and the last was last idea I have c4 you
know it's a positional positional in
accuracy no positional in accuracy you
know so you did
so thanks so positionally in accuracy
and why everybody understand why is he
for is positional in accuracy it creates
a weak square on d4 and he could have
played a move before here and take it
down to show it okay so that was the
idea we have to try to make sure you
don't do that okay
plus you want to open the bishop you
want to open it you want to push the D
pawn not the e pawn here then so let's
say he goes here who can show me a
strong way strong way here let's say
then goes here his opponent goes here
who can show me a strong way to play
against this knight on f3 a strong
continuation yes that's a good thinking
right there I mean Queen here but it's a
one two and you might be able to do
something right yeah how about something
a little bit more direct I like that H
or H try that's good but let's keep that
for a little bit later something more
direct here who can show me a direct
idea here can you see something direct
that you can go for here absolutely
before of course before yes now he
captures that's it now how is he going
to defend this yeah well yeah yeah I
don't think he wants to do that I don't
think you really want to do this this
yeah or otherwise you lose a piece yeah
but if you do that yeah it's very tough
life after this 90 xt5 is coming it's
very bad okay so that is your another at
the end the last moment then yeah you
just you just you just push the wrong
path so here you have to calculate
perhaps maybe in a longer game yeah that
this actually maybe works okay yes
yes right here and take you come back
okay so overall good performance and we
see French defense again proving to be
after right good alright next game we
have this is the game Jason playing with
the white pieces against Humberto on
Orbis 1500 and you want congratulations
that's a couple hundred point upset
right 400 point upset he's eleven
hundred only very nice J's Jason you're
playing with white Bishop f4 is this
what you normally play is this your
typical opening okay II 6 Carson does it
yeah
now Bishop e7 III Castle Knight bTW to
d5 okay
you were happy to see this move because
you're gonna plant the night here right
c5 c3 h6 Wow
that the we consist position that's a
bit strange move right because it does
weaken the we weaken the position here
h6
let's see if he done Knight h5 it's it's
not the move that you know you want to
play because you're not developed so
obviously this is not going to be great
for you yeah it's not a pressure yeah
yeah yeah you you have several mostly
but you know Bishop e5 I know you guys
were saying about the f6 here I mean
maybe knight c6 first you know because
f6 there's a little trick now it takes
and after this it traps your knight so
that would be a little problem okay
so this is a tactical way of to refuting
this okay take take and g4 and the
knight is trapped okay so but I think 96
is a move this is kind of double-edged I
mean it's it's it's not easy for you to
because sometimes this bishop stays it
for a long time but you may as well just
go here this is fine and then you're
looking to play in ninety five ideas
like let's say he goes here there is
some interesting ideas sometimes you can
go here now the knight is hanging right
so if he gets creative and take if it
takes this now look at this check check
and you go here and you get made it very
quickly so but you know this kind of
stuff it's it happens all the time so I
mean you know that you know 1569 level I
mean people will miss it
this kind of stuff it happens so of
course he has to play g6 now and you
know the game the game goes on here okay
back to the game he played efore oh I
don't know about this why why do you
play for here because you have to Castle
first first thing you Castle alright
then you look at this 95 ideas I don't
like the movie for at all you opening
out the position while your king is in
the middle of the board that's gonna be
some problems there right so you don't
want to do that okay so
they for he was just gonna take castle
Jason castles 96 put tonight only five
Bishop g3f for strengthen the position
okay that's what you want to do okay to
be able to get a comfortable position
got it
Jason choose to play efore here de 94 CD
CD 95 I think just play 96 here and you
know now the pawn is under attack
excuse me
take
Quinn takes f6 yeah what's your rating
what is your rating yeah okay yeah so
yeah 93 yeah I think you should have
done this I don't think he should worry
about 95 nice default one is hanging
okay
95 Bishop d2 rooks 96-83 b6 castles
Bishop f6 it's strange you should play
Bishop e7 rook c8 it's about you know
equal maybe even it's about equal I
guess you know the spot on h6 it gives
you some ideas at some point you know
maybe some sacrifices or something let's
see here could you have now this this is
probably not gonna work I was thinking
to play something like Queen c1 and then
yeah but I don't feel it's gonna work
don't think this is gonna work
96th or we have a threat 96 here guys
yeah it works
Quincy one you know that h6 spawn is
always a problem because you have a
bishop there you always have this
sacrifice although although there is
this line here we need let's check this
this is Bishop here
Bishop here yeah I have a feeling that
this is not the right way to play maybe
he plays this move and now he's
threatening to take on d4 and Queen d2
we play I don't tying up everything
bishop see to actually night before
maybe anyway this is too complicated but
if you were canceled you should
seriously consider this okay so you
console he plays Bishop b7 no it didn't
play Bishop e7 Bishop f6 yeah I don't
like this too much because first you can
take I think you know which you did
queen a for attacking the knight Bishop
d7 we should be five okay now some
serious pressure here and also you have
some Roxy one coming you played very
simple but effective
Roxy one now attacking here yeah he
should have he should have done that of
course unnecessarily he got
unnecessarily pinned of course this
should be seven is a much better move
but that was unnecessarily got pinned
Lucchesi 197 Bishop c3 what is the idea
you just i know besides d5 do you I know
you wanna play d5 is there anything else
because it kind of blocks the rock so it
does yeah something like this rook
secured put the looks together ships it
is just a pretty obvious threatenin so
he will probably see it bishop c3
Queen f4 Bishop d2 the question is if he
had gone back when you repeat or will
you take a drawer you would push for a
win
and then you make a decision after okay
but it's good sometimes when the
opponent doesn't repeat because you know
you don't have to worry about it just
game goes on you know it happens to me
too sometimes they you know yeah there's
a repetition but they don't repeat so
it's you know you just move on age three
he's wasting so many temples
okay I like this move just developing
bring the last piece into the game right
f6 Bishop b4 now you want to take this
and then he's gonna have some serious
problem I mean this f6 really weakened
his position really weakened it so he
takes f6 never play yeah yeah now
everything is hanging everything is
hanging now rook takes c1 Bishop e6
check internet so yeah nice Intermezzo
now you take the knight can't go back
but that's another pawn on a7 they're
hanging if nothing else
rook c7 comes in Queen d7 very powerful
move attacking the knight and the knight
moves there is a checkmate on g7 this is
one of your better games now against the
guy who is 400 points higher than you
very nice it seems like you were the
higher rated player here you played
really well congratulations on the win
there were not too many things you could
have done better the most important
thing I think the only inaccuracy you
made is efore yeah I think I feel that
you played really well you know you
follow the earlier so just don't play
you guys
efore it's not good for a few reasons
okay it's it first of all it you know it
gives isolated pawn for white which is
not so good in this position second is
the king is in the middle cells so it's
just way too early to do that okay you
know you would play this move when you
have let's say Casso Queen is really the
only two rookies only one rookies on d1
everybody is in rook everyone okay d1
and then maybe after something like this
you put the rooks in you put your Queen
only two and then this is an idea you
can consider doing this then but you
don't play you don't want to play it now
okay it's just too early
okay okay so that's your game okay so II
for right efore you're playing bla black
Michael d4 Knight f6 so everybody know
this opening yes okay then what's the
what's the opening all a kinda fence
very good
'if I've I lock him 95 c4 so your
opponent very aggressive right away he's
pushing all the puns yeah Knight d6 d4
d6 okay I always thought when they push
the pants like this in the in this aleca
and defense it's not so easy because
then plot gets a good counter play
sometimes it's why they they don't push
c4 right away they go Knight f3 take 95
do that position because here there's a
lot of you have a lot of attack on the
center I think f4 well you need this
section this opening you have to play
this section other kind of course it's
it's your move we got to get the pieces
out and you gotta attack you see the way
this opening works is you lose some
temples they push the pants on you you
back up and then you try to contract ACK
it's very interesting it's quite
fascinating if you spend the time right
now you get a good engine a good
computer you work this lines I bet you
can make this lines work it's possible
to make this lines work you know I mean
now you're not gonna be able to play
this consistently the very high but I
mean there are some grandmasters who
play this I remember a game that I saw
was really impressed by I was I was
actually playing in that tournament 2012
Olympiad in Turkey Istanbul and it was a
match Russia versus USA so Russia was
playing perfect they were winning every
match they drew one they were just
beating everybody
it looked like they're just gonna win
and then they're playing us in round
eight and we're doing okay we're you
know we I think we want every match
withdrew three matches so we were behind
the point to Russia right
and then suddenly so this is the lineup
Russia was very they were very strong
they had Kramnik Greece choke Yaakov
encode one actually he won and Kuryakin
was third so basically they have kramnik
Trisha Kuryakin Yaakov anko was playing
fantastic very strong team so anyway
Yaakov Engel one against rock grey and
then the third where was a quick draw
between honest chicken honest shook and
Kuryakin
so the on a second board it was all a
kind defense that counts to played and
he won that game which was unbelievable
Grichuk was a favorite and he had a
white PC but Matt Kamsky got a nice
position and at the end it was a rook
king for Greece choke and rook Bishop
King for Kamsky and Cook was very long
time so he made a mistake in the theory
difficult defense he made a mistake and
lost so Nakamura won a game against
chronic which was another big story
because he was slightly worse maybe out
of the opening or absolutely equal and
they repeat it twice and in order for
not to make a draw he karo had to place
a really passive knight move because
that was the only way to avoid
repetition but since he realized he know
he cannot just waste the white collar so
he played like a you know really good
team player so he avoided a draw and he
got to this position where hammock was
doing fine but it was pretty intense and
somehow at some point he got the better
of him and managed to win so us one on
top two boards drawn third and that
sealed a match so it was unbelievable
and that Russia continued winning
everything after that they continued
winning everything and then but then
they tie with Armenia and somehow
Armenia passed a multi break and they
won the tournament so yeah
years it's up there I mean it's after if
defense won all that kind won that game
so that's the game you want to look at
it as an Alec I'm player yeah yeah but I
mean beating Greece Chuck a guy it's
it's an unbelievably strong player in a
game in a must-win game at all impaired
it doesn't get bigger than that so I
mean that's gotta come scheming one of
the best players in the world you know
he used this and one so it's the opening
is it still you can play it shows that
so here he played you took check yeah
you take take did you go knight c6 not
c5 d5 c5 it's not so good here c5 d5
it's big problem then your piece no you
played 96 no 96 is fine this is you're
still you're still in your theory right
this is still a book okay Bishop III
it's normal because if you play Knight
after you get into get pinned by Bishop
to here so Bishop III Bishop f5 Wow
and here we see a move that I don't like
at all by your opponent see five pieces
are not developed pieces are undeveloped
you know and he played c5 giving you
that excellent square on d5 yeah but
that's not I mean at least maybe later
on you can play that but now right now
very very strange decision 95 now Queen
f3 he's not developing his pieces and
now while the bishop was under attack he
is attacking you sir
so you played a six plate okay
Essex is normal right but let me ask you
what is the better move that's a good
move but then remember when you see a
good move you look for a better one
right
so what you could have done better here
to win material here right away but yeah
we you basically gonna win like few
pounds probably because his position is
just collapsing here might be five no no
takes no I don't think you can take
it'll take you back I mean this pawn is
really weak okay then
then what's the idea and now how many
attackers you have on this to take now
look at that the center is collapsing
takes look at that night see tour is
threatened
he's 92 is threatened as well so it goes
here now like that is six get the Bishop
out absolutely you win you win on the
spot right here
- too bad you missed this because this
would have given the game you'd have won
the game on the sure but well just just
just remember when opponent does strange
stuff like this it's never gonna work
just try to play a chess game putting
your pieces on awkward squares you know
or do or you gotta follow the rules the
opening principles you have to otherwise
you know like this is just what you did
it's fine you still better but it's just
you could have just won the game here
okay you miss a shot but now you know it
yeah this should be five every okay B
should be five it's ok spinning knight
exit Lee you did it now he took check
this was interesting takes
I took here by the way if he takes on c6
you cannot play the king queen here the
rook is hanging but you can play the
move King e7 it looks like he cannot do
anything you wrap a piece your knight is
still remaining there so he takes Queen
takes III route p8 I like this move this
is a good move developing the rook and
attacking the pawn excellent move b3 he
protects it Queen h4 check oh okay
g3 very nicely done it's a good play
right there that was an excellent play
okay he played poorly but he played
probably with his g3 should have played
King f1 and Knight f3 I I still like
your position but it's not gonna be easy
okay I still like your position but it's
not gonna be so easy to do anything
King f2 thank you very much for the rook
Knight f3 he's trying to trap you okay
the only way he can have a chance to
trap you but he can't Queen d1 can we
back this up yeah how about take another
one increase that material advantage or
not even better
okay Queen d1 is fine to you we're
worried about getting the Queen trap but
this is just winning another piece okay
okay alright so Queen e1 I think you
were just too worried about the Queen
and say let me get out of there quickly
you know and then you treat the Queen's
just to make sure nothing bad will
happen
okay well very good okay
okay the rest of the game I don't think
we need to go over too much you wrap a
whole rock you know so okay very good
okay then I have a puzzle for you okay
to solve
that's a nice victory so let me set up
the puzzle okay it's okay good win one
thing you your only inaccuracy was not
doing this right away
it could have been costly if you were
playing maybe a little bit tougher
opponent and the see fibers are just a
very bad remember c5 is bad if they do
it early like this no that's not this
this is just bad I think here maybe in
other line they can play this but not
here and here your only mistake you know
that could have you know mean anything
is just take just take just eliminate
okay and Queen takes d4 game is over
here position simply collapses okay okay
I have a position for you I will set it
up and you need to find a mate in three
moves you are winning here no question
but you need to find a mate in three
moves you are wide yes the pawn is going
this way yeah that's fine yeah
what can you do here very nice idea
so first idea is you can never checkmate
him when your rooks are next to each
other right there's no way you need to
have one rook to cut another one worked
to check rupee 7b8
further the better remember further the
Bears big difference you'll see now
excellent start okay threatening check
made threatening checkmate so let's look
at all the possibilities you can do so
if the knight gives you check where do
you go excellent King to f6
if the knight gives you a check
excellent
no more checks now no more checks with
the night so you just have to avoid the
checks next egos here 9 c6.r okay 1
mates right not true Kate because he can
cover with Knight f5 Knight c4 ok the
other moves are simple if King moves you
to check this is a tricky one now this
is the best defense here because now if
you check me from a8 I cover with Knight
a5 if you check me from a1 I cover with
Knight a tree so you don't have a way of
trying to check maybe minute so you need
a very special move here to get the job
done so what would be the move here to
to break the balance here to be able to
win yeah but I'll just check yeah I mean
you win the night you win the game no
problem but we're trying to win in two
moves you have two moves to find the
checkmate now
not always is gonna be checked check and
mate sometimes you need to find a quiet
move suck so on very good sucks man
Isaac specify specifies rook 8 B 7 Isaac
excellent look at that move now the
whole point of this move is you pass the
turn to him
so pawn cannot move on the king and the
knight can move right if the King comes
here what do we do
perfect checkmate if he goes this way
what do you do
aha the King moves we have made we know
that so the other thing left now the
knight moves correct
if it goes Knight a5 ok one mates
if it goes Knight a tree okay seven
mates if it goes this way
no no not whichever if you check with
this one it goes the knot whichever be
specific then that is the mate right
there and if he goes here ok one perfect
alright ok excellent
so these are good to do it you know they
will help you a little bit with
creativity to see that you know
sometimes you need to find quiet moves
and you will see some nice ideas like in
particular this knight c6 just broke 94
rock piece 8 p7 ok alright guys so we're
done for this class we have another
class starting immediately so thanks
everybody for watching coming here and
we'll see you next time
you
[Applause]
[Music]